we're done
no more
that's enough
what's up guys i'm nietzsche i'm a tasty
producer and today i'm going to be
testing the george foreman quesadilla
maker
i'm going to be seeing if it works if
the quesadillas taste good and if it's
worth buying let's make some queso duos
boom here she is nice bright red color
it says here we've got meals in under 20
minutes but on this other side here it
also says like done in less than five
minutes
what is a quesadilla meal so done in
less than five minutes it says here that
sounds like it's a little bit faster
than it would take me on the stove it
says it's also done without oil or
butter which is interesting because at
the top here they've got a nice like
brown quesadilla you know i would think
that you'd put some like butter on there
to get like a nice little sear like that
we'll see if it turns out the same way
when we make our quesadillas so let's
break this thing out and see what it
looks like
this looks very simple looks super clean
it's a nice bright red color it actually
reminds me a lot of the pizza maker that
katie did a gadget review on we are five
minutes in and there's smoke ladies and
gentlemen click the link in the
description if you haven't seen that so
i guess this is how you secure it we've
got like a handle here seems a little
flimsy honestly like even when you put
it down you can kind of just lift it
back up
we got a nice non-stick coating which is
always important because something like
this you can never put in a dishwasher
or anything like that so hopefully we'll
see if we can clean our mess up at the
end if that works it looks like it's got
grooves here so maybe it kind of cuts it
for you while you're making it maybe you
can just like grab it and pull the
quesadilla apart and you don't have to
cut it everything else seems like a
pretty standard so i guess at this point
the only thing that's left to do is test
it out all right we are ready to start
cooking with this thing so i'm gonna
read our first instruction here plug it
in and wait until the green preheat
light comes on so let's do that
okay so our green light actually turns
orange so it's not just off and then i
guess it will turn green when it's ready
so the second step says it's going to
take about five minutes for this to
preheat and then to put a prepared
quesadilla inside of it as opposed to
building the quesadilla straight on the
grill i'm gonna start with a plain
cheese quesadilla and then we're going
to do another one with a whole bunch of
ingredients load it up and see if this
thing can handle it lots of cheese i
love cheese you want to leave a little
bit of room around the edge so that you
know all of your cheese doesn't just
like ooze out completely i'm sure this
thing won't handle that very well all
right let's put the top one on here
quesadilla now we just gotta wait for
this thing to preheat and then we'll get
this party started so i've been sitting
here waiting for our like preheat light
to turn green but like that orange light
that i said earlier just turned off but
it doesn't turn green it just turns off
so i guess when it's off it's ready
and when it's
on it's not
but now that it's off i think we're
ready to go let's open it up
this thing is
hard to grab with just the i'm all right
i can feel the heat radiating from this
thing seems pretty strong the box said
that spray oil or butter isn't necessary
but the instructions say that i can use
it but i'm going to do what the box is
and we're going to go without it and i'm
just going to put this straight on here
so
let's get to cooking
so closing
my quesadilla is not super
there you go the box says this should
take under five minutes and the
instructions say three to four so that
seems like it's uh consistent we'll open
it in three minutes see if it's dark
enough and then we'll let it go longer
if need be there's a nice sizzling sound
that's happening right now that's like
making me excited i feel like once we
open it up it'll be nice and golden
brown listen to this
let's open her up what do you guys think
is it gonna be brown are we gonna need
to put it back in or no what do you
think what do you think what do you
think
okay
all right i'm not mad at this at all you
know we got like a little bit of a like
golden texture here all of our cheese is
spread out a little bit probably went a
little bit too heavy things to note when
we load this up and put a lot of
ingredients in here but everything's
looking really nice i'm going to let it
go for maybe a couple more minutes just
to see if we can get it like nice and
perfectly golden brown on the top there
and then we'll pull it out excellent so
we've hit our time let's open it and see
what it looks like be careful opening
this because it is is a little bit
snappy all right so we let this go it
looks really good still got that like
nice brown on the top hasn't been
overdone oh look i don't even need to
just like a perfect little pizza just
nice and even real light stays together
looks good so i know the speculation was
that maybe we'd be able to just pull it
apart once we finish cooking it but i
don't think that there's any way that
this is going to just pull apart you
definitely have to cut it
nice and crunchy so my first impression
is that the outside is really crunchy
which could be really nice but i'm also
a little bit afraid that the cheese on
the inside also looks like the cheese on
the outside that maybe it's not like
oozy maybe it's a little bit overdone on
the inside but when we do the next
quesadilla i'll let it go for a little
less time all right let's see how it
tastes
this is really funny actually
so this has a really great taste but i
think we definitely let it go a little
bit too long there's literally like it
there's barely any cheese actually
registering in there there's like a
little like bed of cheese that's still
on the bottom but i guess it all like
baked sideways or something so i've
learned a lot from this one it's really
tasty but i want to make our loaded
quesadilla and see if we can make it
better so it gets one more chance we are
ready for our second attempt we're going
to do a loaded quesadilla now we've
learned all that we need to learn let's
see if we can make a perfect quesadilla
i've cleaned this thing it was super
easy the non-stick coating totally works
out it was just a little bit of grease
from the cheese wiped it up with a paper
towel no problem so let's close this
thing and let it pre-heat again i've got
some ingredients here that i'm going to
add into this loaded quesadilla we're
not going to go too much because it was
already having an issue with just cheese
pushing this down but we've got to
refried beans cheese of course some
chicken and then we'll add some toppings
at the end like salsa and sour cream all
right i'm gonna start with my beans here
some nice refried beans now let's add
some chicken so i'm gonna try and erase
this chicken similar to the pattern of
the inside so it doesn't like get stuck
when we try to close it we're gonna put
our cheese down now an idea is that
we're gonna get a nice even melt and
it'll just ooze down nicely i don't feel
like we put enough cheese
more cheese when is cheese the bad thing
boom
all right so my quesadillas done my
light has turned off we're preheated and
we are ready to go let's put the sucker
in there
[Music]
closing it up so for our cheese
quesadilla i actually had to force the
latch down and force it closed but this
one i'm not going to do that the
instructions actually say if it doesn't
latch all the way that's totally fine so
i'm just going to close it over the top
of our quesadilla and let it do its
thing and see if it works out i'm going
to let this thing go for three minutes
and hopefully that's the perfect amount
of time and we'll check back in after
that all right we've hit our time we've
got some nice sizzling going on i can
see some cheese leaking over to the side
let's open this up and see what it looks
like it smells real good too by the way
not as browned on the top as maybe i
would like it not as much as the last
one but because we overdid the last one
i'm just gonna say this is good let's
take it out always super easy never
sticks
so this one didn't stay a hundred
percent closed but i think it's a
combination of the fact that there's so
much in there it didn't close and we
didn't force this uh lid down here but
that's totally fine it's not coming
apart no big deal all right let's cut
this open and see how it turned out this
one also seems like it's cutting a
little bit easier maybe because it
wasn't as crunchy that we didn't let it
go as long
it's oozing out as i cut it it's always
a good sign
let's see how this thing did even though
this didn't get fully golden brown on
the outside it still has a nice crust to
it and it feels like our ingredients
aren't super dry so i really think we
let it go for the perfect amount of time
so i'm kind of excited about this it's
not too full this this is a pretty good
quesadilla just from the look of it all
right
this tastes delicious it's absolutely
gooey you could see all our chicken in
there our cheese didn't melt away it's
like the perfect amount of everything
even though we didn't close it down like
these edges aren't like super open so
they're not like flimsy or anything this
quesadilla is really nice there's still
a nice crust on it even though it wasn't
perfectly golden brown everything is
very flavorful but you know use
flavorful ingredients this is a really
well put together quesadilla if we're
just degrading taste right now i'm
giving this thing an a i'm really
impressed with the ooze that we got out
of it the crust that we have on the top
of it and just the taste of the entire
thing this is an a for me i'm actually
very very impressed if you serve this to
me at a restaurant i probably wouldn't
be like oh what you know like this is
this is good i'm impressed good job good
job george
it's hot so we've made our quesadillas
the quesadillas are really good but how
do i feel about the george foreman
quesadilla maker overall i think this is
actually a pretty good product i'm
impressed it did what it said it was
supposed to do even though we couldn't
close it it still got a decent like
golden brown crust on the outside the
cheese melted all the way through and it
was really cooked evenly throughout the
only thing i don't like about it is if
you like a thicker quesadilla it's kind
of hard to judge how much you can put
inside of it and still get this thing to
close so with that being said i'll give
it a thumbs up do i think you should buy
it if you're a quesadilla lover this is
absolutely the product for you it's
quick it's easy and i'm happy with the
way the quesadillas turned out well
that's it for the george foreman
quesadilla maker if you have any
suggestions for other gadgets that you
want us to try let us know in the
comments below but until next time my
friends see you later oh yes
[Music]
you